[Music]
ten crop top king hollows a nice try
chopping how about you shut up oh yeah
yeah yeah ah ah well that'll be
submitted by jetan from Buffalo New York
ah Buffalo the place where the wings
came from embarrassing footage of
Thailand's King wearing a crop top a
pumpkin authority to threaten legal
action against you I saw this [ __ ]
that's it's [ __ ] funny dude why is
the king of Thailand wearing crop top
because he's a [ __ ] king you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want I just you
just kind of watch this video oh my god
oh no
ken hilarious is it that hot where he
hates that much ventilation I guess see
the king of Jamali is doing the same
[ __ ] Hey I don't wear crop tops okay you
were short short you do this to your
shirt yes you know why I could it's more
fitted we don't need to know why I'd
rather go shirtless than crop top come
on
I know rains off crop tops so this is
king maja which was captured in a mall
in Munich Germany when a Munich wear
crop tops well [ __ ] you William I
initially thought that this is happening
in his like palace that's right not to
oh my god is that in public and
apparently is wearing fake tattoos I
wanna do that no I'd be shirtless
everywhere crop tops it's kind of like
wearing a bra I wouldn't wear a bra
laptop already satellite something in
the Thai language you [ __ ] up ha ha ha
here you go look kid Jill okay
oh my [ __ ] god who is he with his
eyes white oh those are big tattoos I
thought he was a badass King like you
just like dating supported that there's
favoritism there's other photo of him
also in a crop top yeah with no
toothpaste different edges are crop tops
in in Germany I don't think so I'm
guessing Germans are trendsetters for
sure but crop top wise I can't think he
has how to wear that I can't say it let
me let me ask you this do you think
that's one of his concubines or do you
think that's a shopping buddy I think
that is his shopping buddy or do you
think that's one of his bodyguard
assassins oh he's better where she has
the chloroform towel
it's crazy cuz he's just by himself with
her chameleon he's eating yogurt there's
no like other bodyguards
the corners of the room with the
earpieces not there you can see it isn't
a double ganger because the Thai
government is saying like they're
threatening to press charges
oh they [ __ ] up to the Thai Facebook I
would be like that's a doppelganger yo I
don't have any tattoos That's not me
he looks just like him though yeah I
don't Canada like he has a very distinct
asian angry message there's 2014 they've
been having these let a majestic process
prosecution which means I say it's
against it's a crime to make fun of the
royal family or say anything bad about
my family so this video they're calling
in an illicit video because it's very
embarrassing another key so there were
tied tourists or something that
recognized the king and then they're
like oh my god I know what the half what
the hairs are here how coming in a crop
top I know yeah this is it a cut top why
the king in a crop top oh I guess that's
a lesson to all your royalty out there
if you want to go and explore and you
don't know what normal clothes look like
just pay a visit to Old Navy first yeah
this is the other
the other photos that we release of him
in a different class
he just likes crop tops thank you life
crop top didn't mustaches oh he got the
low-ride jeans so I thought it was a
something out of this was just something
she liked to do like secretly so [ __ ]
him now that I see this with this
entourage and all that I think he's just
comfortable in his own skin but those
jeans are riding too low that looks more
than a crop top looks like a cotton
sports bra yeah and then apparently what
they're saying is that these tattoos
they're different from the other tattoos
right that's what we call mr. country
what is all he wants to do is be a sexy
ass girl who did the exploring walking
might he might have body dysmorphia
where he thinks he looks [ __ ] fly oh
the world needs to see this is my query
David all guys have it that's a pretty
flat stomach for old man how old he's
borderline getting that V thing in 64
years old
luckily I can be good for 64 where the
crop top 64 year old King shut up maybe
he wants to be shirtless but because
he's still royalty he has to cover his
nipples that's why the crotch shot - uh
crack so somebody's hurry up again the
[ __ ] male rapper did you see me
because because that that's possible
Robin yeah of the robbed him I'm sorry
give him a romp him because at least
that's in fashion and the nobody could
really like you know dogyum on that [ __ ]
it looks like a tank top and then you
cut them right here the belly part I
just don't even know how to used to loot
them seriously you're the [ __ ] Secret
Service you know like this and then this
ball comes out of the [ __ ] there Air
Force one and he's like I just have that
I'm in Germany and it starts coming down
and there's like what the [ __ ] I don't
even not to take him seriously because I
thought it was like a code of conduct
that they have to follow because you
know when like at least in England there
they have like you know they have to
dress a certain way there's even words
they can't be yeah so I thought it was
like
you know royalty code of conduct and
then the way they have to dress like I
would not allow my king to step out of
my country I think when he lands with
plane goes like this and then as soon as
the door opens its like disco music shut
up amigos
that's so shameful he looks kind of
trashy it is the most difficult thing on
earth to imitate the Thai language that
language is [ __ ] insane
it is hard pretty crazy - there's a lot
of like rolling up the arse it just
sound like somebody's having a seizure
how do you say his last name
it's probably like when you have a Thai
last name right if you've ever been to a
Thai fast-food restaurant
their name will start here and it'll end
on the red cake possession and [ __ ]
long dude yeah this King is the his name
with Maha his name is Thailand King King
Vegeta longhorns
Jia Jia but you're a longhorn that's a
Charlotte it lives away longer and more
complicated insects actually now using
my favorite but they got some long axe
names though like Tim Tims let girls
realize Hannah's long fun countenance
ooh yeah Thai food is delicious though
really spicy man every time you go to a
[ __ ] Thai restaurant like video one
medium or do you want hot and medium is
already [ __ ] blazing hot so any of
you white people out there if you go to
a legit Thai restaurant to say medium
say no spice and they'll still be spicy
note nice
yeah I'm good mild yeah it will [ __ ] you
out it hot yes if it'd iam is burn your
[ __ ] ok hot is burn your entire
organs yes in spicy is just forget about
it okay forget about it
do you think you for Joe Mallya would
you prosecute people for embarrassing
you embarrassment is not a word that I
understand but that's have any argue so
the [ __ ] you embarrass him already
embarrassed
little me to be a lot if you get
embarrassed by the king you die oh yeah
there you be a shame of your king that
with the crop top crop top
next I say this 2014 we prosecuted over
a hundred over a hundred people like
they were arrested so many people for
for this not [ __ ] fair dude if you're
walking out looking like that that blows
my mind is no one tells the King like a
king you you know you do you want to
just like stay at home with the crop top
black kind of hard to like you know city
pet wardrobe person that can give you
warning who regulates the king no no but
you know like the king they have like a
circle of advisers right like yeah maybe
the Kings I want to kill everyone maybe
don't say that maybe you can save it
like they're always kind of soften
things up I have a good public image
like there isn't someone that's just
like maybe you should stay away from the
cotton sports bra yeah and here's
Dockers Levi's vans some really normal
[ __ ] and then you stop putting on fake
tattoos I'm tired of spending 30 minutes
a day putting on fake tattoos I mean
let's try to sell you are the king of
Thailand you're about to go out of crops
up you really really want to wear this
crop top and you're the advisor you're
about to walk outside now go excuse me
your highness sire the Holy Ghost of the
heavens of Moy Thailand please do not do
not wear the crop top but this is my
favorite crop top
what's wrong with a crop top just to let
you know there's news in from Milan and
everyone is wearing scoop necks much
booty short about that but I am a
trendsetter
everybody loves and knows me okay I
don't want to die go ahead now you guys
got the real scoop hey guys thanks for
watching this episode if you want to
submit your own articles check out the
link in the description box below and if
you want to see more videos check them
out right over here
[Music]